بابتسامه عريضه كما اعتاد ان يظهر في
الصور يتحرك ياسين بونو بثقه ليلوذ عن
مرمى بلاده قبل انطلاق ركلات الترجيحيه
امام اسبانيا في دوري 16 يتحدث مع خصمه
ويتخذ موقعه ويتصدى لركلتي ترجيح ويساعد
بلاده على التاهل لاول مره الى ربع نهائي
الممتعه
بعد مباراه اسبانيا التي امتدت اصلا لاكثر
من 120 دقيقه بخلاف الضغط النفسي المصاحب
لركلات الترجيح يتحدث مع الاعلام هو عن
براعته في التصدي لركلات الترجيح يقول ان
الامر ببساطه ما هو الى بعض من الحدث اكثر
ياسين
داخل الملعب والوداع خارجه لا يثير ضجيجها
في تحديات ناريه قبل المباراه او ينتقص من
خصم منا فقد يتصدر اسمه العناوين كبطل او
حامي عرين الاسود او قاهر احلام
البرتغاليه رجل المباراه المره الثانيه
على التوالي في المونديال بعد اداء بين في
نصف نهائي لكنه يختار ان يهديها لزميله
يوسف مصيري صاحب هدف اللقاء الوحيد امام
البرتغال لكن بولو لا يريد الاكتفاءه هنا
يقول بعد مباراه البرتغال نحن هنا لتغيير
العقليه لقد غيرنا عقليتنا بالفعل والجيل
التالي سيعرف ان المغاربه يمكنهم صنع
المعجزات